welcome to intelligence squared thank
you very much to Hana now I'm sat
between a politician who's often
described as a rock star and a rock star
who's an artist and activist and a rock
star so it has to be said because I
don't think I'll ever get the chance
again hello London
I'm undoubtedly playing the role of
gooseberry tonight because Brian Eno and
Yanis varoufakis are long-standing
friends their shared interest in
politics and ideas with practical and
philosophical is more I think than just
bar side banter
they're both also involved in a
political project Yanis is co-founder of
DM 25 the democracy in Europe movement
2025 and Brian's a leading member of it
and I think some of the movements ideas
may actually come up get an airing
tonight so the introductions now Janice
was was absolutely certain that you'd
know all this anyway but I'm going to
remind you anyway he's an academic and
former Greek finance minister failed
Greek finance minister in his words I
think it would be first so he defies
pretty much every Finance Minister
stereotype we've ever heard and leather
jacket and a motorbike there his sort of
trademark style his profile soared after
he took office amid the Greek financial
crisis in 2015 and at the time he
described the austerity measures that
were being prescribed for Greece as
fiscal waterboarding and terrorism these
days Yanis is a member of the Greek
parliament and he's a professor of
economics at the University of Athens as
well as a professor a visiting professor
of political economy here at King's
College in London Brian Eno is a
musician and an activist who's wove and
I think it's fair to say into the
soundtrack of many of our lives
certainly mine he's probably one of
contemporary music's most influential
and innovative figures he began his
career playing synth with Roxy Music in
the 1970s and after leaving the band I
think in 1973 he developed what he
called ambient music a sort of cloud a
sound an idea that's entered very much
into the mainstream and has been widely
copied ever since he's worked with
artists including David Bowie
he heads Grace Jones and Damon Albarn
now Brian and Alice I daresay you have
better things to do than watching a
program called through the keyhole ever
either have you ever seen that no okay I
please do you have it actually anyway it
was presented by no that other line I'm
relieved this is if you listen to radio
good and evil program anyway presented
to the moderator yeah she worked that
out it's presented by a guy called Lloyd
grace Minh he was a Canadian with a
really strangled accent and basically it
used to take us around a celebrity home
and it was sheer voyeurism there was no
other way of describing it well we want
to have an element of that tonight I
want you to pretend that the two of you
are kind of having it a bit of a you
know you're hanging out you having a bit
of a bar side chat we're not really here
imagine that we're kind of at the back
of the bar washing the glasses right
we're not here and we will all get to
join in a bit later because you'll get
to ask questions and say well I so what
happens when Brian and Yanis you know
sort of shoot the breeze down a glass of
something or two what do you talk about
what are the biggest problems facing us
right now and we can talk a bit about
solutions let's start by talking about
how we fit in brian is as individuals as
a society what are we facing as problems
and what are the issues about
individuality versus society well I
should first of all say that we mostly
meet in front of a large audience ruin
that then it's true we often do meet in
this kind of situation because he lives
in Greece and they live here somebody
has to pay the air fame but well I
suppose the thing that has been
obsessing me for quite a few years is
where does creativity come from where
does intelligence come from and I'm more
and more convinced it comes out of
communities rather than as we tend to
think out of individuals it comes out of
the whole sort of quagmire whole ecology
of thinking and doing some of it looks
like intellectual who
some of it doesn't but it's what
produces new ideas so so I often say now
that new ideas are usually articulated
by one person but they're nearly always
generated by a lot of people and we tend
to reward that one person at the expense
of the of the other people I've been a
beneficiary of that what reward system
but I'm more and more suspicious of it
and do you think that the individual the
interaction of the individual with
groups of people is the crucial part
there I'm thinking about the band the
way a rock band works the world that you
work in what is that interaction well
it's very interesting I often use the
word chemistry which is word everybody
uses but that I mean it in a very
literal sense if you take iron 100% iron
you have iron there's something that's
brittle heavy and so on if you add four
percent of carbon to it you get
something called steel and that's a
quite different material and very often
the chemistry of bands is like that that
there's one person who makes a lot of
noise and seems to be the leader and
there's very often one other person who
doesn't make very much noise but
actually is equally indispensable and I
find that's true in all sorts of social
situations as well one of the things
that came to interest me was those
creative situations called salons which
very much were part of the late 19th
century in the early 20th century salons
were nearly always large groups of
people many of whom don't remain in the
history books but actually were part of
the ecology including particularly the
hostesses who usually were putting these
salons on and bringing people together
mrs. Dalloway yes yeah
Yanis come on the individual and ideas
and creativity and solutions listening
to Brian by the way when we are on our
own we usually have the same kind of
conversation so either were very
interesting or exceedingly boring there
we do this is the kind of thing we talk
about yeah yeah why do we will make out
this is something that you know with
we've spent hours talking about
regarding the individual I want me to
come to the subject from my own trauma
of being an economist because anybody
who has had the tough luck of having
studied economics even very little
phenomenal you will recall that the
first page of you know introductory
textbook defines the rational person
Homo economicus it's always a he because
only a male could be so deprived and
depraved so that the the individual is
defined in economics as a bundle of
preferences seeking satisfaction given
constraints and your ration to the
extent that you maximize your preference
destruction given the amount of money
you have what other people who appear in
the scene of economic theory as an
obstacle so community instead of being
empowering is you know is what jean-paul
Sartre used to say other people are help
but he meant it in an existentialist way
the economists actually mean it
literally now this is of course
effectively what you have is a Robinson
Crusoe approach to the economy if you
look at look at the Bank of England's
econometric models that the Bank of
England uses in order to predict
inflation unemployment breaks it as if
they can never predict what will happen
with praxis given a there's a sample of
zero to work with but anyway so all
these models are predicated upon the
assumption that the economy is founded
on rhombic on cruiser and his clones
they have no relationship except that
through the market mechanism so buying
and selling
no one influences anyone
there's no money and there's no debt
because you cannot have money without a
roommate it's like language remember
what became Stein used to say there can
be no such thing as a private language
language something we create together
you know if you're a single person on
the planet and you're grown up on your
own there's no way you can have a
language unless somebody taught it to
you
so this rather sad depiction of the
individual which by the way the Savage
is at the heart of the way in which
mainstream economics thinks about the
world and one may ask the question so
wise is the case are they not
philosophically sophisticated enough
know the answer there's a lot of money
in it because the whole point about
mainstream economics is to justify
capitalism and capital justifies itself
on the basis of the fiction that wealth
something that is produced individually
and then the state comes and taxes it
when it's exactly opposite wealth is
produced socially collectively and then
it's privatized so this juxtaposition
Jackson position between the individual
and the collective this is the dominant
ideology which supports profit-making
and a particular kind of class structure
it's the sermons it's the religion it's
the theory it's a place exactly the same
role that the Middle Ages the bishop in
legitimizing the power of the emperor of
the lord of the baron of the king and
what we need to do we need to dissolve
it and Brian Brian gave me a fantastic
example not example idea of how this is
dissolved think about the economists
model of competition right it's it's a
bit like a kind of Olympic sport where
my victory is your loss but the far more
interesting model of what happened
in the world is the band where you know
you've got highly individualistic people
usually on this clip on the stage but
what's going on is while at the same
time from each one of them trying to
prove to the audience into each other
into themselves that they're the best of
the lot unless there is the chemistry
and as there is the synergy each one of
them just creates noise carrying on from
that I would say that the the other
limitation of conventional economics or
classical economics it's not only that
it's focused on the individual rather
than the community but it also has this
notion of externalities so that things
that can't be monetized things that
can't be expressed in terms of money are
not considered part of the picture you
don't even think about them so that
means that leaves out two very important
at least two very important worlds one
is the environment if it isn't price
level you don't count it it's a resource
for you to use and the other is care
caring all the things that traditionally
women did and still do which aren't paid
for so you know the classical story that
if if I have a housekeeper and I marry
her I've actually reduced the GDP by
doing because there's no longer a
transaction of money between me and
there so that seems ridiculous doesn't
it but that is still the basis of
economics we're still calculating GDP on
the basis only of exchange of money it's
not a floor of economics or is that a
floor of politics any attempt
distinguished between economics and
politics which are economists yeah
invest in men's energy in making that
distinction any such attempt leads to
really very stupid economics and toxic
politics think about it you know
buying a tub of yogurt is a political
political act in the sense in a sense
that you are channeling resources to
particular individuals the particular
companies to a particular foodstuff that
is a political choice in a well in a way
it is something that shapes society to a
tiny little extent even mother Thatcher
acknowledged that remember when she was
towards the end of her career as Prime
Minister her tenure as prime minister
and she had that moment of clarity when
she said something that was correct and
not particularly misanthropic
in opposing he only happened once I
think he happened a few times by
accident but you know she was she was
extremely smart so smart people if they
keep talking they will say something
something profound a simple but she made
the point in opposing the eurozone and
the European Central Bank that was in
the making of the time remember one of
the last speeches in Parliament field
was Prime Minister's question time she
said who controls monetary policy and
interest rates controls the politics of
Europe they are any attempt to
distinguish Polish polish from economics
is bunk in which case if you're talking
about the project that is Europe and the
politics and economics that underpins it
you're very critical of the way in which
Europe functions right now and we've
been having our own rather vigorous
debate is it the politics in economics
is it the individuals is it the the way
in which it was set up where do you even
begin on that look I think most of you
to be here know that we supported remain
a radical remain okay we said European
the European Union sucks it's really
additive anti-democratic but you should
stay in and we should fix it together
and there is no in coherence involved in
this it's like saying hey
the prime minister of this country
because I love this country there's
nothing in contradiction here right so
having said that this is for full
disclosure purposes
look my view about the European Union is
that it was it had a very bad start in
1950 behind all the lofty ideals which
will break you know wanting to end all
war all wars in on the continent of
Europe and bring people together it was
all great but if you look at the
construction it was a cartel of big
business the first name for the European
Union was a European community for cold
steel like no topic and the whole point
was to limit competition in order to
maximize the profits of these big
businesses and then they copped it you
know the French farmers they gave them a
cut of the industrialists profits when
you create a kind of state apparatus in
the image of a cartel this is by
definition the opposite of democracy I
might talk about cooperation efficiency
words like other parts where they can
talk about you know the transhumanism
for a long I care the fact is that the
bureaucracy in Brussels was put there in
order to serve the interests of big
business and to keep the riffraff the
demos out of any democratic process and
effectively to take decision-making
capacities from democratically elected
governments and throw them into this
hole of this cartel okay that doesn't
sound like a great eulogy for the you
like you're a fan given so Tony Benn was
right to pose and you know British entry
into European Common Market in my view
but it's one thing to say we should not
have gotten into this cartel it's quite
another thing to say 43 years later that
should get out because during those
forty three years you have all sorts of
social norms that have merged rasmus you
have whole layers of legislation you
have industry standards you have
environmental protection standards you
have worker protections
it's not just you know a curve L it is
something much bigger than that and it
is impossible to disentangle yourself
from this without creating toxic
politics in your country and also
precipitating dynamic within your
opinion which will turn the European
Union to far more aggressive continent
which is not bad for you given that that
whatever you do you can't sail away from
this part of the world and sail towards
the United States or China despite what
Nigel Farage Boris Johnson may want so
my view of Europe is this is how it
started the crisis we see in the euro
the crisis of legitimacy of the European
Union is it is a natural repercussion of
the its original architecture as a
cartel what we must not do is transform
it and democratizer
this is why diem25 began in 2016 with a
slogan they you will be democratized or
it will disintegrate and what we are
trying to do is to prevent its
disintegration because it's going to
have huge political economic social
aesthetic cultural costs upon all of us
by democratizing it by putting the
Demers into what is supposed to be
European democracy but I wonder if for
you when you think about climate change
I'm going to turn a little bit of a
corner because like what gangsters to
make sure we have enough time for
questions when you think about climate
change then is the EU the vehicle within
which you can tackle that this big
undemocratic cartel as the annus
describes it well it's certainly a much
better vehicle than Britain on its own I
think for sure it already has started
making steps in that direction and in
fact we have already been sharing in
those and probably will would now be in
the process of trying to revoke them if
we do brexit but the more important
issue for me is thinking where does
where does power actually lie and I
think what has happened in the last few
years because of this the joint shock of
Trump and brexit is that people have
started becoming empowering themselves
again
they've started becoming empowered I
mean I'm particularly aware of this in a
America because I have quite a lot of
American friends who are intellectuals
who for years and years would have
absolutely nothing to do with politics
they were sort of libertarians who
thought politics as a sort of old
business technology actually is moving
much faster than politics and technology
actually predicates our politics so
suddenly they're thinking Oh pulling out
of politics wasn't such a smart move it
just left the ground to people like
Trump so same thing over here I think
suddenly we're all engaged in a way
again and in fact one of the reasons I
do things like this is because I want to
say to people actually anybody can be
engaged you don't have to have come from
a political background
what you have to want to do is to take
hold of what power you can get hold off
and do something with it and I think the
way that power structures change is is
actually quite subtle I think the
existing power structure becomes more
and more fossilized it becomes less and
less able to respond to the people it's
supposed to be governing you can see
this very clearly I think happening both
here and in America so what happens then
is those people have to make ad hoc
arrangements themselves and get things
done themselves bit by bit they become
the new they become the government that
carapace that fossilized carapace still
exists and we still have to pay for them
just like we still pay for the monarchy
and we still pay for the church and we
still pay for all these layers of
carapace that we have above us but the
real work of social change is being made
by people often working voluntarily
actually people who belong to NGOs who
are in neighborhood groups to change
things to improve the local school or in
big organizations like Greenpeace and so
on but it's it's those people who are
propelling change know much more than
politics or politicians who are
generally sort of obstructing it by
their fossilized nurse but isn't there a
tension between that vision and more
Yanis is describing can you read
democratize a fossilized carapace if
that's what we're talking about I I
think I have a one thing I'd like to say
about that about the idea of democracy
there's a little-known American
political scientist school who has the
unfortunate name Charles snap Schneider
and that's why he's so little no nobody
can remember it and he said he said a
really wonderful thing he said democracy
is a process for people who are not
certain that they're right and I think
the most interesting thing about the
possibility of democracy is that you
kind of draw you crowdsource basically
you draw intelligence from everywhere
and that's exactly what we haven't been
doing for the last few years we've we've
individualized politics to such an
extent that you know we end up with
these sort of charismatic figures like
Trump and Johnson and Thatcher that
isn't the way to go first on the green
you deal and the European Union I have
no trust in the European Union's
tendency to implement again you deal the
way it's bureaucracy and politics
structured it will not happen
they will make all the right noises
because they use fantastic labels
packaging euphemisms and all that hides
in activity in action I look at Germany
for instance foreign you know it's
amazing that is a country accounted be
swimming in surpluses it's got a budget
surplus a trade surplus surplus of
corporate savings hospital savings and
they're not investing in anything
serious I mean their infrastructure is
crumbling they're still using lignite I
mean it's pathetic
right but the European Union has the
instruments that could be pressed into
the service of a giant green you deal
and I'll give numbers now five hundred
billion pounds every year at least at
least is the minimum we need in Europe
five to eight hundred
billion pounds every year he sounds like
a lot of money it is not do you know how
much money is washing around in the City
of London doing nothing being uninvested
it's about the trillion so only in
London imagine in the whole of Europe
it's about four and a half trillion in
Europe excess savings liquidity doing
nothing other than bidding up house
prices they're not doing but but the
European Union has the institution's who
have the European Investment Bank which
sounds boring and it is boring and it is
in blacksburg of all places that's
really boring but is anybody here from
nightmare I'm sorry but do you know it's
four times the size of the World Bank it
has the capacity to energize all this
excess liquidity especially if you have
an alliance between the European Central
Bank the Bank of England under a Labour
government allowing me to you know make
a party political broadcast here go
Jeremy but if you if you have an
alliance between the central bank of
Europe of Britain of Denmark of Sweden
and the European Investment Bank a new
investment but not a public investment
bank that you need with this country the
equivalent in Germany kfw right
you could really affect and implement a
meaningful substantial green ud but to
do this to utilize those institutions
need the demos to rise up and it will
not be a question of persuading
politicians that they're wrong it's a
question of overthrowing them replacing
them so you know the extinction
rebellion people the fry this for future
people they have to take over politics
and not disintegrate the European Union
but use those wonderful instruments that
are they're sitting doing nothing or
very little that is useful and press
them into a into service and one last
thing
allow me to say look I have a message
for you folks stop whinging
brexit has been a very good thing for
you not getting out of your opinion but
it has reinvigorated democratic politics
this country people talk politics again
youngsters are interested in politics
again that that is a breath of fresh air
that is something to harness its energy
not in order to get out of your opinion
but in order to felices everybody now
sees that there is a majestic disconnect
between Parliament and the people
between the elites and the people okay
fine do not surrender this to the
Pharisees of the world make sure that
wishes becomes a good reason to recon
reconsider the electoral system the
fraudulent first-past-the-post which
will never love this country to be fully
democratic you need assemblies like that
to grow and to become citizens
assemblies to discuss again the
Constitution of the United Kingdom that
needs to be written down and needs to be
reconsidered you need an English
Parliament you need you will decide what
you need but this is a fantastic moment
in British history and just to conclude
there are two ways of big nationalistic
one is to be to adopt you know the
exceptionalism mantra that our country
is exceptional it is much better than
other countries and so on but there is
another way of being a meson nationalist
and this is one must avoid inverted
exceptionalism account is the worst look
the political system is broken down
directs disproven nothing is working we
are the worst of the worst
no that is another kind of nationalist
we are not that special
you're not worse than the Germans the
Greeks the French our democracies are in
trouble that's why we need to get
together at a European level at an
international level to put the demos
back into democracy and you're doing a
good job visa good start keep going
there's so much owner unpicked there I'm
not gonna be able to UM pick it all but
one one small point before we actually
want us to go back a little bit as well
and he I was interested that you use the
people this is the Parliament kind of
narrative because many people reject
that they see that as a that they're
it's not about her a disconnect between
Parliament and the PBC huge disconnect
you have first-past-the-post you know
such a used to win election of the
election of their election with a
minority okay that's not democracy but
he's agreed to change that system isn't
the debate and the tension right now
about putting in place a referendum into
an into a political setup that is a
representative democracy and those two
things sit very uncomfortably next to
each other well that's only because you
you know your democracy has been stunted
with by first bus the post and the fact
that you only had three referenda the
Swiss have a referenda every Monday
Wednesday and Friday they incorporate
reference the referendum process
perfectly and beautifully with
parliamentary democracy this is so one
of the important things of course is
that they actually explain what you're
voting about in exactly is referendum
and they keep having them so they can
keep changing them on their minds and so
on he says you know you have wonderful
Angela that's it finished for the the
problem with the second referendum that
I filled in the last couple of years
that's why I was never in favor of the
second memorandum was a view probably
the last if it ever happened it would be
so toxic it will be probably boycotted
by levers and then there wouldn't be
another referendum I think the referenda
are important I also think that they
need to be combined the Irish example
with the referendum on abortion rights
it was crucial because very so how a
parliament was locked into a debate it
could not escape from the straitjacket
that it had found itself in and what
unlocked it was the citizens assembly
which prepared the public for a
referendum that was well informed and
then that went hand in hand with
Parliament so we need to combine
Parliament referenda citizens assemblies
okay let's move on a little bit cuz I
don't spend all the time talking about
the issues around brexit but you also
talked about
the green New Deal and the need for the
demos to rise up and and push this idea
forward
what about co-opting the bankers Mark
Carney's talks recently on several
occasions about the importance of green
issues to business and that actually it
should become fundamental to the ways in
which businesses see themselves and
their future and indeed giving the best
to their shareholders or whatever their
priority is is that a way forward
I have a very hired a girl from one she
didn't say that he didn't talk about
copping the bankers because no I'm never
I'm saying suggest that I guess he knows
that they cannot be co-opted to a good
cause right what he said is if you do
not move towards sustainable investments
you're going to go bankrupt these you
know but they would notice against their
nature to do anything good so allow me
to be very specific we're here in London
where they we're not far away from the
city of London I'm going to say
something which is very heretical but it
also happens in my understanding to be
totally true this country needs to
shrink the City of London by a factor of
90 percent the argument that the City of
London is good for this country is a
complete and utter fallacy it is a drag
on the rest of the economy it is pushing
productivity down it is making Britain
into what it has now become in the last
20 30 years of the financialization went
crazy it's tying London into Notting
Hill it's tearing up as seen in the film
movies they yeah yeah and you know and
so the argument that that the city has
to be competitive and it must accumulate
capital it's exactly the opposite of
what is true so you need fewer banks
fewer bankers they are effectively a
sinkhole that absorbs and extracts value
fraud from the rest of the economy
and the result is that the majority of
the people are not left behind they are
held behind by financial
financialization it is preposterous that
the asset books of the City of London
contain loans that are five times your
GDP this is this is something that you
should look at as a threat to the
cohesion and future of this country the
city is the problem then where is the
answer where is the money for the green
new deal for instance well one one place
is tax havens you know one of the really
big problems we face is that so much of
the money that moves around England
doesn't ever get taxed particularly the
money of the very wealthy like that
another place is this ridiculous thing
of high-frequency trading where money is
being created in nanoseconds why isn't
that that would be a very simple thing
to restrain at least there are many ways
I think that we could be looking at the
flow of money and seeing how we could
make it fairer and more rational but
we're not doing it at the moment well
they're two points also throughout to
this I buy the green you deal and how to
finance it the first one is a technical
one you don't need a financial center
that has five times its GDP of money of
pieces of paper sloshing around doing
nothing productive France which is not
in a great state of health either has a
much much much smaller financial sector
and average ability poor productivity is
higher than 25% higher than Britain and
Inca proportions higher than Britain so
you don't need the the financing of the
green we deal we will require taxing
wealth ending tax havens and so on but
it that would really not be at all
enough even if you introduce a wealth
tax like the one that Elizabeth Warren
and exactly okay your quarters are
proposing in the United States all you
will be able to raise is about 1% of
it's good but it's not enough we need
five six seven percent to have a green
transition that the creation of the good
quality jobs that we need in this
country in Europe and so on the main way
of energizing this excess liquidity is
what I refer to before public investment
banks that issue bonds that operate like
sponges that soak up the liquidity from
the real-estate market from the share
buyback process which is boosting share
prices without an investment without any
quality good quality jobs and the
central bank's just announcing to the
market so they would support the bonds
issued by the public investment banks
that was the New Deal idea originally
Franklin Roosevelt
it's how he managed to prevent the
perpetration of the Great Depression in
the United States that basic public
finance idea but beyond that we need to
reconsider the model of capitalism that
we have because think about it every
time you use an app to buy a train
ticket in this country right you know
that 75 P goes to train line train line
belongs to KKR you've never heard of kko
kko almost boots the chemists did you
know that did you know that behind the
the majority of the corporations and big
banks like JP Morgan's in the United
States Bank of America US Bank Walmart
and so on there are three companies that
you probably have never heard of
Blackrock Vanguard State Street have you
heard of them they own 70% of capitalism
right and your little 75p every time you
buy a train line ticket yeah so the
slashes around through there so you have
a situation where the railway railway
system in Britain is siphoning anything
between 170 and 200 million through the
apps that you use to buy a train ticket
and that finds itself into the KKR tax
havens of the Cayman Islands and so on
so forth now that effectively is a think
of it as a system of extracting value
from the real economy and suffering
siphoning it off to create this you know
the the super super super each of 0.1
percent as long as we keep doing this
there will be no greedy because those
people will always own the media will
always own Facebook or be able to you
know to buy as many as many you know
sponsors ads on Facebook to poison
politics and to poison democracy unless
we combine public financial tools that
go back to have their roots in the New
Deal of Roosevelt with a challenge to
the property rights over apps over
Facebook over railway systems we are not
going to be able to save the planet and
create jobs that stop people from
feeling so angry that they vote for
Johnson fives
another another thing to add to the
train line story is that train line is
owned by a nested series of 26 companies
so train line is owned by another
company called train line Hg which is
owned by another company called Hg
Holdings so on and so on there are 26 of
these in a row and why do why do
companies do that do you think it's so
that they can never be identified that
where the wealth is can never be pinned
down so they can never be taxed is a
solution to that global national is that
for a government tackle is it the
government's the tackle is it going back
to organizations like there I say at the
g20 which are unwieldy unlikely to make
a big decision it's all of that we have
to act local original you know
neighbourhoods everything but it's but
you know it's a good start is to mean a
tional eyes the railways yeah
and have an app that belongs to the
National Railway Company it's a good
start
terrific
and another very good start would be to
acknowledge the idea of the Commons that
there are things that we share there are
things that should not be privatized
abour we used to accept that until
Thatcher really who came along with
there's no such thing as society
following in an rands footsteps of
altruism is evil if you remember these
two great statements of the twentieth
century but those two those two ideas
were really that the basis upon which we
dissolve the notion of the Commons the
Commons is not only to do with pieces of
land we know of that kind of Commons
where your sheep can graze but it's to
do with intellectual property it's to do
with Commons of knowledge it's to do
with shared resources shared resources
being not only physical things so we
have to start thinking of the flow of
energy and and wealth in a in a country
in a nation as something that we have
common interest in it can't be just
hived off and nested in 26 a series of
26 companies and end up in Arkansas or
whether we're at KKR somewhere like that
hundred yeah what is it about kki is it
control 200 companies and have four and
a half thousand companies registered in
the cayman islands through which to
control those 200 companies uh-huh and
did you know that there's there's an
address in Harley Street number 29
Harley Street which has 15,000 company
headquarters at it and if you call them
somebody will answer the phone and
she'll say yeah sorry day I can't
connect you with them that it's it's a
completely fake address but it's because
England is now that the money-laundering
capital of the world
it really is actually we we are the real
criminals in this that's what happens
you get but it's seen thousand done yeah
this is a lot of collective guilt
because I'd already of the bloggers
people or other victims of the city of
London yeah this is so much to unpick
there and I know I'm not gonna be able
to unpick at all and
they pick one small part though do
either of you accept though that profits
and making money is a force for
creativity it's not the primary force I
don't think I don't know anybody who is
excited about what they make because
it's going to make them money I know
people who are excited about what they
make and who would like to make money
from it and are happy when they do but I
don't I've never met anybody in my
business anyway of whom that's the
primary motive
happiness stems from bleeding from doing
something creative something worthy and
if you get some money for that as well
then you are the happiest person on
earth mmm the trouble is that the
connection between getting out of
poverty and hard work has been broken
and a connection between doing something
creative and making lots of money has
been broken this is the problem with
capitals but allow me to give you a
little hint of how that because becomes
a systemic failure you know Karl Marx
was talking about the class struggle in
Manchester how you know the capitalist
is invest in a machine the the worker
has no alternative but work there and
the value of the labor power is lower
than the value of the product you know
but now if we've really moved to a
science-fiction version of this think
about it imagine you're the CEO of a
large company let's not mention one you
are beholden to the expectations of
these kk RS and black robes because they
own the companies that own the companies
that they that own your shares okay so
whether you're going to get a bonus or
whether you're going to be reappointed
depends on those people pension funds
your equity firms private equity capital
and so on the workers contribute as part
of their you know pay as they earn to a
pension fund the pension fund then is
owned or owns
the company that effectively drives the
CEO the CEO any CEO if if a CEO today
wants to make a little bit more money do
you know what he has to do is usually he
you know what he has to do just
announced that he's firing 30% of the
workforce it doesn't really matter
whether it this will reduce profits
increase profits whether it makes
financial sense whether it's from an
accounting perspective the right thing
to do
any CEO who announces a Cal of the
workforce will immediately get money why
because the stock exchange immediately
reacts to use of you know the
redundancies we by boosting the price of
the shares a boost in the price of the
shares always transmits into a boost of
the bonuses of the CEO so the thing
about this is this is this is this is a
an evening planner ileum and it's a very
clever plan but it did nobody planned it
it's something that evolves
spontaneously within monopoly capitalism
the worker pays part of his wage into a
pension fund which then demands of the
CEO that the work is fired so that the
share goes up bid was
it's a circle I want to just a couple of
things before we open it up to everybody
here who've been busy washing glasses
you haven't noticed they were there one
is this idea of the worker of capital
linking back through we talked about
climate change I wonder whether you
think a lot of this could be made
redundant first by the changes that
climate change may bring and secondly by
AI people are talking about thousands of
10 hundreds of thousands of people
losing their jobs white-collar jobs
blue-collar jobs because of AI the
driverless car the law firm that can you
know look at contracts simply by putting
them through a computer the sort of the
the the joining of those two events how
dangerous is that are we even thinking
about how they might interact some
people are this very interesting new
book by Stuart Russell just came out
which is about the more dystopian
possibilities of a a I I can't remember
the name at the moment I'm afraid but
the the interesting thing about AI is
that really we should call it machine
learning yes AI is a different thing we
haven't actually got too much of that
yet it's machine learning and machine
learning is looking at lots and lots of
data and finding patterns that aren't
intuitive that aren't obvious without
machine learning system and then trying
to create responses based on that and it
would be very interesting if we said to
a machine learning system what should we
do about climate change if we trusted it
enough to actually take its results
seriously because I think it would be
revolutionary if we if we did accept
that we were now in a position where our
own intuition was not sufficiently
evolved to deal with this very complex
and big problem and that we needed that
kind of help I'd like to see the results
of that
what what I think is happening now is
that we're moving into a sort of
non-intuitive phase of our history the
complexity that we're dealing with is so
so rich and as as any of you who know
about chaos theory will understand the
number of outcomes the number of
possible outcomes is so large that we
need help in dealing with this we can
get that help by crowdsourcing by
trusting each other's opinions and
amassing them and looking at how well
the data is being digested but we could
also do I think somewhat with machine
learning I'm alone among my friends in
this because most of them deeply
distrust it but I'm alone among my
friends and also thinking that we should
be now looking at nuclear power as a
serious we we were talking earlier about
you were mentioning lignite the Germans
using lignite why are the Germans losing
lignite the dirtiest fuel on the planet
because the unfortunately the German
Greens persuaded them to shut down their
nuclear power stations I wasn't a good
Germany's Angela Merkel deciding like
that after Fukushima that she would get
more votes if see something done yes
maybe the Greens had no influence
Langille America they were they were
seeing our support of an opportunism
yeah but they were happy to support it I
remember we were having a chat
backstage beforehand and we said that we
were asked to you I disagree on anything
and we couldn't find anything disagree
here we found something disagree on
against nuclear power and you know why
not just because of yeah the fact that
we don't know what to do with nuclear
waste but primarily cost Italy now I
mean you're right ten years ago when
medical made that choice it was a
mistake from a climate change
perspective but now to start designing
and building new nuclear power stations
irrelevant the cost and efficiency of
wind and solar has become so wonderful I
mean are you aware of them the land area
involved to try to replace coal power
it's it's not a question I totally agree
now right now now we I would live in a
velocity world the capacity have
floating solar panels and wind turbines
that will produce a hundred percent of
energy within the next five years around
the world this is this is now clearly
feasible with existing technology not
which we have to we have to look at the
arithmetic of this yeah we'll look I
mean people have looked at this very
okay look we are disagreeing or
something but let me go to the to the
key question about AI and the
singularity moment that people talk
about it there will come a moment very
soon maybe six months or two years where
the number of jobs created by the new
technology is going to be far far less
than the number of jobs that will be
destroyed because yeah every
technological innovation destroyed jobs
but up until now it is been creating
more jobs than it has been destroying
and now the singularity moment is when a
I will destroy 45 percent of professions
all in one year or two am I going to
interject at the same time you might get
mass migrations of people leaving areas
that are no longer inhabitable because
it's too hot to drive that is flooded
that's great
so here is the thing from where I'm
standing
given the exponential growth of
productivity of capital of machines
machine learning robots and so on so we
are capitalism is going to run out of
puff because in a sense with private
property rights over the robots
concentrating on so Fame such a small
percentage of the population you're
going to have a society that can produce
all sorts of goodies but there will be
no demand for them because the masses of
people would not be able to for them so
you what you're going to have is a
situation where you we're never going to
get full automation you're going to have
a dual Kaname
you're going to have fully robotized
plants already we have go to to the
Apple manufacturing plant in near Austin
Texas that produces all the
the math books there are hardly any
workers hardly any workers and at the
same time you're going to have areas
where people work like machines with
very the mechanization because human
labor will be so dirty
almost slavery that there will be no
economic reason to introduce robots so
we're going to have a you know this kind
of awfulness the only solution I can see
to this in order to turn the robots into
humanity's slaves rather than allowing
them to turn most humans into the slaves
of the robots and of the owners of the
robots is to have a situation where a
percentage of the sales we can start
with 10% of the shares hola of
cooperation with more than 500 employees
go to a sovereign wealth fund I would
like to get global one and all the
dividends accumulate in there and that
becomes a fund from which you disperse a
small initially universal basic dividend
not income to the extent that capital
machinery you know to think of of the
Google engine every time you search
something in the Google engine you're
contributing to the capital of Google
but you're not taking any of the
prophets the prophets are privatized so
they're the capital is socially produced
the profits will that directly to the
shareholders only of Google so imagine
if we said look folks if you really want
to be listed in the stock exchange and
have the license to operate and so on
ten percent of your shares would have to
go to a common kitty to the comments and
then the dividends that accumulate
they're divided and as AI progresses and
Robert ization of the month of project
progresses we can go from 10% to 20% to
30% in the limit you have market
communism because if that goes a hundred
percent all the corporations are owned
by everyone all the dividends accumulate
to everyone but you still have markets
functioning so well how about going to
soviet-style
failed commons experiments but we are
talking about
a different way of combining Commons
with entrepreneurship with technology
and then if we are as the demos the
owners of capital then you can direct it
towards the green transition practices
that will save the planet that's a huge
thought I'm gonna put it out there there
were so many huge thoughts and I know it
may not have seemed like it but I was
desperately trying to keep my mouth shut
there's so many things I wanted to ask
but I'm gonna let you do some of the
asking now so please ask brief questions
so we can get as many in as possible
there are people wandering around with
panels or if you're upstairs there are a
couple of mics on either side so I think
probably come up to the front perhaps
and queue near the mics that might be
the quickest way and basically I'll take
three at a time and we'll try and get
through as many as we can is that right
right right let's go to number three at
the front here let's take the gentleman
there so my question is two parts really
I mean I just think that surely social
media badly miss named kind of very much
gives the illusion of engagement and
what's exciting about what's happening
in Britain today as Janice referred to
is the return of actual activity of
people on the ground and surely we need
to do more on the ground in the
community rebuilding social activity and
also in relations that's what our
Parliament has done in recent months is
what it should do it's taken heed of the
split in society and continues to the
debate that's what's exciting there
needs to be more activities for all
three people on the ground more
rebuilding of structures on the ground
and and that's what will lead to
fighting for pride for more progressive
ideas in society okay number one at the
back there thank you
yes two related questions about the
green you deal and how it would be
funded when when you Yanis have talked
about the funding before you've talked
about the European Central Bank which
would obviously funds bond
in euros there how does that work for us
who are outside the eurozone and I hate
to shudder to think of it but we might
be outside the EU when when that comes
about and secondly so I just like to
work out how that actually works for us
in in Britain but secondly the other
thing as well would you agree that the
this funding through bonds the bond
issue is also a kind of democratic as a
democratic bonus to it as well because I
have a friend who's an Indian who
remembers a time - immediately after
independence in India and the Indian
government issued a massive bond issue
and it had a real feel of people power
about it everybody took out their
savings and book share about bonds in
the government because they wanted to
because they wanted to participate in
the in the whole process of a lot of new
independent India and could we see the
same sort of thing happening right
across Europe people buying into the
green new doing that way I came in
I'm gonna come down to the front woman
they're just there yeah hello good
evening just would like you to comment
on movement and radical change I'd like
to mention two very important ones the
BDS and extinction and what is missing
okay okay right are you happy don't we
should repeat them is everyone happy no
I think we I think we got them all Ryan
do you want to go first take as much or
as little social media okay which I of
course call anti social media because so
it's been so disastrous I think as an
experiment in sort of unchecked
unplanned and thought out capitalism
essentially do you know it's a great way
of making money as you can see she says
opening her iPad
well I I don't actually have any social
media accounts myself and I don't plan
to so I don't know if that makes me a
Luddite or if it makes me it turns out
to be rather smart and I know that a lot
of people I know and now abandoning
their social media accounts but but I
think the question was also saying what
we're also seeing is real activism yes
I've renewed kind of people on the
street literally yes
Yanis said something earlier which I am
very attuned to which is the notion that
we what we've been doing for 40 years is
privatizing the profits and socializing
the costs
unfortunately social media has become
another version of that all of the
activity the work is done by us all of
the profits are taken by Mark Zuckerberg
and a couple of others I I don't think
social media a useless at all and I
think they're going to be very important
at the moment I think it's one of those
Commons that we have to take over again
it cannot be run by private companies it
just will not produce the kind of
results that it needs to produce I don't
know what you feel about obviously well
look I think that we need to look at
what the Chinese are not copied for god
sakes
but look at this because what the
Communist Party is doing they're saying
okay Twitter out Facebook out we're
going to create our own versions and
anyone who does not any of the business
people who are running those social
media who do not conform to the
standards of society are going to be
expropriated now I wouldn't want the
Communist Party to decide who gets
expropriated who doesn't but imagine if
it was a citizen's assembly process the
determined whether the social medium
that belongs to the Commons changes its
bosses because they're misbehaved that
could be something I can I can easily
live with now let me answer your
questions about the green you deal of
course the European Central Bank cannot
back British green investment bonds but
imagine if the Bank of England which is
your central bank and they see be forged
an alliance they do it all the time
no they only do it in favor of banks No
yeah the green transition of the people
so they could have a collab and anse an
alliance and the alliance would be for
the purposes of funding a green you live
in Britain in Sweden in Germany anybody
in Turkey we can expand the limits of a
EU without even expanding the you
because this you can copped these
different countries even if they're not
in the U or even if they have left with
you anything and you have the public
investment banks issuing the bonds
collaboratively so the European
Investment Bank the German investment
bank the the biggest investment bank if
you manage to create one jeremy manages
to create one and the central banks also
for join this alliance there you would
have a big bazooka against climate
change you would be able to have a
substantial amount of money that we
throw directly into renewables and
directly into AI that is going to be
used for good purpose electrification
across Europe and effectively creating
fantastic jobs for the people in Britain
and that would create also synergies and
I think it would actually result of the
more optimistic its actions that you
would get if you get a feeling of petrol
you know if you if you have a thousand
quid or ten thousand quid or three
thirty thousand what's the point of
putting it in Lloyds Bank or Barclays
Bank when you get no interest and you
care you pay fees and so on if this bond
system it has a decent interest rate
yield which it will if it is invested in
the real production capacity then yeah
that's why the bankers will fight this
tooth and nail as for movements I think
you should answer this question in BTS
in particular who we came on I said
there are two subjects that if they come
up will never get off them brexit and
BDS I'll let you speak briefly then on
answering this question and then we can
move on okay first of all I should say
what BDS is for the benefit of those who
don't know it means boycott divestments
and sanctions and it particularly
applies to the cultural boycott of
Israeli government supported culture
it's the it's the one thing that has
completely unified the Palestinians who
I mean 99% of them support BDS and and
asked us foreign alt artists to observe
BDS it's as far as I'm concerned a
question of judgment there are good
arguments for saying that the existence
of BDS hardens resistance to change in
Israel I think they are some quite good
arguments there are also good arguments
and I are on this side for saying that
BDS is the only thing that the Israeli
government has ever felt threatened by
and this seems to me to be fairly
obvious so that they now have a special
department in government to deal with it
and they work very hard to do
credit it I'm not going to talk anymore
about BBS because it is such a
complicated subject and it can we could
be here all right what was the other one
extinction well that's a great thing to
see I'm very happy extinction rebellion
exists i I want to see movements of that
kind happening at every social level I
don't expect to see 60 or 70 year old
university professors going out with
doing the same kind of movement but I
hope they do a movement I hope they make
a movement and I think as Deanna said
that what we're seeing now in England
for the first time since I was quite
young is a society that is engaged in a
commitment to change some kind can I say
a few words about PDF as well because
this is free fallin especially amongst
our comrades in Germany I worry about
videos even though I support it and I
worry bit because it's so easy for
anti-semitism to sit into any movement
like that and I would prefer to you know
die in a ditch than to be associated
with anti-semites or to be in a movement
that is easily infiltrated by
anti-semites but then you know we have
to balance that fear with another fear
the fear of forgetting the Palestinians
and you know just leaving them to ethnic
cleansing and this crime against their
human rights the bush is happening under
the express policy of apartheid by
especially the recent Israeli government
so how do you balance the need to
prevent and the anti-semitism from
seeping in with a need to fight against
apartheid when there was apartheid in
South Africa BDS was strong you know I
used to live in this country back then
you see demonstrating against apartheid
and we used to call upon Thatcher
to impose boycotts on Berkeley's Bank on
all the companies that would you know
functioning in South Africa and so on I
was not against the South African people
with a little black or against it was
against apartheid so you know that one
trillion pounds is how can we combine
boycotting apartheid while being solid
aristov the Jews who feel threatened by
anti-semitism that is the question I
know it's because the the easiest
defense against BDS is to say it's
anti-semitic and that's the defense that
the Israeli government always uses so
it's it's always tried to make BDS look
like an anti-semitic movement it's the
same technique that's been used up
against Corbin of course you know that
that is one way of weakening somebody
because that's such a that's such a
fractious area - okay I am actually
gonna move away from this because I'm
glad you betcha yeah there is so much
move away from controversy well because
I want to get some more questions in
otherwise we can the rest of the time
talking about it I'm gonna go upstairs
this time so there's a woman in the red
jumper there if you want to come down to
that microphone down there thank you I
suspect you guys both agree that we are
going through a major transition as a
society and as a world really and
technology has generally brought seems
to have been the cusp of these big
transitions how do we get better at
reinventing ourselves how do we get
better at at this process of constantly
transitioning to be 2.0 3.0 to become
better as societies because I feel like
every time we have to go through it it's
because there's a lot of pain there's a
war there's angst that leads to it and
so how do we start to learn from this
process of reinvention and get better
and get processes in place that allow us
to do it peacefully and equitably okay
and then on this side there's a
gentleman there if you want to step up
to the microphone do if you're if you're
on the balcony and you want to ask
questions there are microphones on
either side hey that apologies for the
slightly boring question on this one but
what do you think on the ECB's policy
Pro long
negative interest rates and what effect
that's having on the everyday person do
you think it's good or bad and
ultimately what do you think can be done
practically for the ECB to come out of
this cycle of just continually cutting
rates every time there's some sort of
economic you know worry if that's what
needs to do okay and one more at that
thank you so my question is specifically
relating to companies such as Google and
Facebook and given the extremely
sensitive situation with regards to a
private date and privacy what do you
think will constitute the individual's
freedom and integrity in the place where
effectively all your opinions and
everything all your preferences are
known to the companies before they even
known to you thank you
okay so we're in the midst of a
transition how can we use technology to
reinvent ourselves and become better
I think the ECB and negative interest
rates is definitely one for you Yanis
and data and privacy have we given away
our freedom and privacy where are we
left as individuals well to the first
question you have to remember that
everything to do with the internet came
out of a kind of stew of utopianism that
brewed up on the west coast in the 80s
and 90s and it really was a very utopian
vision suddenly we'll all be able to
talk to each other what could be better
there's going to be world peace
immediately I was part of this and even
believed it for a few weeks ago sort of
1989 to five minutes you know it seemed
like what could go wrong suddenly we can
all communicate all of those barriers
that have been keeping us apart
geographical and cultural odd they're
going to disappear we didn't see the
other side of it at all i think i think
people Jaron Lanier was one of the first
people to start seeing it in the 90s he
started saying this doesn't look so good
and of course the person who saw it most
was Evgeny Morozov who wrote that great
book called the net
illusion and the second book was called
to save everything click here their
growth brilliant books but nonetheless
California carried on with the myth you
know imagine the future it's yours sort
of thing but I think what we could do in
future is perhaps proceed a little bit
more slowly and not proceed at the
breakneck speed that was predicated
entirely by the fact that there was a
race going on between these companies to
claim as much territory as they could
you know it was a real sort of armed
struggle going on there's a great
graphic going around at the moment on
the internet showing the last twenty
years of the internet and the primacy of
different companies and you see them
gulping each other the process was
nothing whatsoever to do with social
well-being nobody in that process was
thinking about that they were thinking
about territory we want the biggest
possible audience we want than maximum
number of eyes so it was to do with
advertising essentially because that's
is after all what the Internet is paid
for by so can we perhaps in the future
not have it dominated by advertising you
know again this has to be thought of as
a commons I think and if it's a commons
it's it's beholden to a citizens
assembly of some kind it has to be it
has to share our intentions and our
needs as well okay and I wonder if you
wants to also talk about possibly our
relationship with freedom and privacy
specifically if we just given that away
well you have I didn't sign up well
firstly on the question of rings
reinventing ourselves and getting better
well first thing we must not do is
indulge in self-help books and that
culture oh you know voluntarism where we
you know we are going to do a little bit
of recycling and feel that we've done
our thing
this is a collective enterprise you must
get together in four movements and you
know reinvent ourselves through
democratic participation part of that is
actually as you say not taking
responsibility for something we are not
responsible for you know there are
processes that produce this situation
and they weren't of our choice actually
so to sort of take all the blame on
yourself and say I have to improve my
life that's that's a bit of martyrdom
that you don't need to do really exactly
exactly
and because you had an American accident
didn't you it it gave me a couple of
ideas well we need to borrow ideas from
interesting social experiments and
economic experiments allow me to say
that I'm a great believer in
restructuring our socio-economic modes
of production
along the lines of NFL the National
Football League let me make the point
here let me remind or tell those who
don't know of it that the NFL is a very
strange competition so you know when it
comes at the end of the season or the
beginning between seasons to replenish
their talent their player stock the
worst team gets the best available free
player in similarly in Major League
Baseball you have a salary cap and teams
that pay more than a certain amount they
have to pay 40 percent tax to the teams
that don't have enough money to pay
salaries okay that's the kind of
socialism effective what you're doing is
very distributing to the weakest why
because competition is mummering
much more interesting when you don't
have Google and Facebook you know and
Walmart destroying everybody else so you
know how about reinventing Society by
combined
wonderful socialistic ideas with the
National Football League and all and
finally on this issue again because of
your American accent I'm going to give
it an American example don't call those
who vote for racists racist or
deplorable it is not a good idea
so I'm not being Chris you know
Christian here but you've got to
understand those who voted for Trump
over breakfast for four hours whatever
okay you've got to try to get into their
shoes not in order to be converted to
their way of thinking but you know when
you hear a blue-collar worker in
Minnesota wherever refer to Latinos or
Mexicans as rapists because they heard
Trump say that these are not merely bad
people they're people in despair because
if you look at the social statistics in
the United States also anything that in
the United Kingdom you watch any Ken
Loach movie if you don't need to read to
read statistics okay what what you find
in the United States you have
blue-collar workers that have lost their
job in a mass layoff they are completely
hopeless and they have to go through the
indignity whereas these are the people
very same people that used to call
welfare queens the black women who were
on welfare they have to go and register
as disabled people too because there's
the only way of getting some benefits is
to pretend to be disabled at that point
the moment we become welfare recipients
the people that used to call welfare
recipients welfare queens suddenly it's
not enough to call welfare queens the
blacks and the Latinos they have to call
them scum rapists they have to and you
have to you don't have to agree with you
don't have to like them but you have to
understand them and you have to explain
to them the circumstances that led them
to this that this is not the Latinos and
it's not the blacks but it is capital it
is a Wall Street it is Obama's
reappointment of Tim Geithner you know
to take America
out of the post-crash period by
effectively refloating the bankers who
brought that to disaster upon those very
same people on the question of the year
negative interest rates negative
interest rates look it's like you know
blaming the messenger it's like shooting
the messenger the European Central Bank
sets negative interest or one very
simple reason they have a mountain of
savings and liquidity and very little
investment so think of it as demand and
supply when supply is huge and demand is
low supply of money the amount of
money's investment supply of money is
the quiddity available what happens when
supply far exceeds demand the price
keeps falling
unlike potato markets and markets for
cars and so on in the money market the
price of money which is a interest rate
keeps falling supply will not be
eliminated because investment will not
pick up investors think oh the interest
rate is going down so if I borrow money
to invest that'll be great but that's
not what they think you know what they
think when they see B's reduce interest
they say oh my god
Mario Draghi thinks you know the future
is going to be [ __ ] so I better not
invest so the problem gets worse what is
the solution the Green Deal funded by
bonds from the European Investment Bank
and the other investment banks with the
ECB I'm some of them to repeat it I've
already said do you know this idea of de
Mirage currencies yeah I think that's
such an interesting idea de Mirage
currency is is that a currency that
actually earns negative interest so the
longer you keep it the less valuable it
becomes
and it's an experiment that has been
tried a few times and I think we need
electronic mind for that yeah well we
own it it's the band cash and that
becomes a very big thing it doesn't have
a below exclusive but the solution is
not a negative interest the solution is
to take the excess liquidity and and and
invest it in the things that humanity
needs yes but the thing about de Mirage
currencies is they encourage that
because it's to your advantage to keep
it they encourage spending which is not
the same thing as investing the things
we need you know markets
I don't trust markets really no I
haven't ever seen the market if I can
trust as for the big tech question it's
really very simple change property
rights again I'm going back to that
issue of changing property rights you
know I'm an old Marxist there all the
things yeah I'm just against a situation
where the means and the tools of our
reproduction are owned by the very few
so now data is a means it should be
returned well I'm not here I'm just
becoming a convert to private property
make it genuine private property you
know your data should belong to you and
to no one else and put this in law well
this is this is the experiment it's low
parcel owner is trying national it's 829
one more one quick one more okay you all
right guys all right so I'm going to
take those think there's one up there
and there's I'm gonna take one at the
back there and that's that's a lot yes
lady there don't do the one at the back
first yes you're right now keep it brief
and I'm going to ask these guys to keep
your information tonight thank you very
much and I want to ponder about the
democratization of information flows in
the role of WikiLeaks in democratizing
information flows about money and power
and I'd like to hear your opinion about
the threats to Julian Assange the
founder of WikiLeaks and his potential
US exploitation in trumps America thank
you laughter be brief uh-huh gentleman
up there just a very very quick one I'm
sure everyone's familiar with a back
catalogue of Roxy music but there's
someone I'm guessing both of you
gentlemen here are familiar with is
Nicholas Jackson yes and he's a finance
Cornhusker see yeah I was - halfway
through to the moment it's a great book
yeah but I was wondering the vast
majority of my friends in London are of
the opinion the City of London
creates an all thought of tax revenue
and delivers it to the rest of the
country is an exporter to the rest of
country tax revenue
however if one accepts the premises of
the book all they're doing is destroying
wealth and their profits of destroying
that welfare giving a few small crumbs
back which i think is probably the truth
but unfortunately the vast majority of
people United Kingdom perhaps in the
West think that the huge financial
markets are forces for good they work in
this free market which is a great thing
how are you going to disavow them of
that okay love you I quit we're gonna
have to do this really quickly I'm sorry
because we are really over time now so
your view thoughts on Julian Assange and
the role of financial markets two big
questions I totally accept we we both
know Julian and we both visited him when
he was in the Ecuadorian Embassy several
times each I guess and it was certainly
a form of torture and he's now in an
even worse form of torture he's in
solitary confinement
Yanis talked to him very recently he's
quite ill so whatever you think about
Julian Assange from what he did this is
not what he deserves
he's being tortured as sinful when I was
a young person like I think most of us
upon reading 1984 or was 1984 I was
terrified because I could see that it
was this was coming brick big brother
was coming the technology would always
improve and who's going to have it Big
Brother and we will be under
surveillance the first time I felt a
glimmer of hope that this can be
reversed was when I read about the work
of Julian Assange even before he started
WikiLeaks and his great brilliant idea
was to use Big Brother's technology to
turn it into a digital mirror and turn
it towards Big Brother so the rest of us
can see what Big Brother is doing the
reason why Julian is now in
Burma's prison 23 hours a day in
solitary confinement which is something
that is not even done to the worst
multiple murderers in this country every
day 23 hours a day he's in solitary he
has one hour a day it's because he
exposed the crimes against humanity that
were performed in our name in the name
of the West in Iraq here there in
Tunisia and so on and so forth that is
the only reason and I think that those
progressives who have every reason to be
critical of some of Julian's choices as
I was regarding seeing Nigel Farage
supporting Trump in the vain hope faint
hope that maybe he would be released
from the his predicament they should
apologize to their own conscience for
spending the last seven eight years
saying that he is running away from a
rape charge when it is absolutely
abundantly clear that there was never
such a charge and all that is going on
is his meant to effectively perish in a
supermax prison in the United States of
America for embarrassing the national
security apparatus
there's lots of lots of things in there
to unpick and it's quite difficult to
move on but I am gonna make you move on
cuz we are over time just very briefly
then this question of the financial
markets it's clear that neither of you
particularly fans in the city of London
how do you convince people in the UK who
believe actually that wealth that's
created in the city flows to the
citizens I just would like to add
something to what Yana said there's
another organization which is turning a
mirror using the same technology to turn
a mirror back onto power and that's um
an organization based in London called
forensic architecture they're based at
Goldsmith's and if you don't know about
them really really have a look at them
they're the most interesting group of
people doing fascinating work using
quite complex data analysis to tell the
true story of some things that
governments have been lying about for
some time so I just want to tell you
about that in case you don't know about
it as for the city of London well first
of all the notion that they're paying
lots and lots of taxes is almost
laughable because they are the biggest
of all the tax cheats in the world so so
they're not actually contributing even
on that level very much the the other
problem is that they suck out so much
talent it's like the Department of
Defense in its relationships to
scientists do you know the huge
percentage of British scientists work
for the Department of Defense what are
they doing we don't really know but that
talent is actually as I mentioned
earlier is commonly nurtured it's the
product of our society in our education
system and so on and so on and lately
it's worse than the Department of
Defense because the department defense
they do some actual innovations which
eventually you know like the internet
came out of the American debt on the
offense but these people are pushing
paper around all they're doing is
creating more complicated forms of debt
there's no social value whatsoever in
what they're doing
zero the only innovation that has come
out of the financial sector
was the ATM and on that positive thought
I'm afraid I going to leave it there
because we are over time and out of time
you